well let's i want to expand on this but
i want to start with this next story we
have check this out
from cbs 8 researchers say voters are
leaving the republican party recent
studies show the republican party is
losing voters after the riots on capitol
hill last month
they say voting experts at the
university of florida say thousands of
voters are no longer registered with the
gop
they say far more republicans than
democrats are changing their
registration
and it's happening here in san diego
county too the interaction of the u.s
capital on january 6 is something most
people thought they'd never witnessed
now political research says the fallout
from that day shows
thousands of registered voters fleeing
the republican party quote
these republicans are rejecting trumpism
a brand that they see continue to lead
the party
even after his defeat and california
secretary of state's office shows
over 33 000 voters have left the gop
since the right of the capital
in san diego county more than 4 700
republicans have defected
now i i want to ask a question how do
they know these people are leaving
because of the riots
that's i was just about to say that
maybe maybe they're leaving because
trump's out and they don't care about
the republican party
i think i think it's more of the fact
that republicans have been
the the establishment has taken over the
republican party and they did not do
everything they possibly could
to keep trump in office well i think
it's the way around i think trump
infected the establishment like he
forced his way in
and then as soon as they had the
opportunity to get rid of him they did
right no they definitely did i'm totally
with you on that one yeah
but i'm saying that one of the reasons
and i've talked to a number of trump
supporters who
who are you know on the fgop
bandwagon they believe that
the republican party didn't do enough to
keep trump in office believing
obviously that the election was stolen
and that
when it comes to how the gop
is now they sort of embraced it
they embraced letting trump be expelled
from office right and didn't do enough
what what do republicans do
what do they fight for is there is like
a specific issue republicans are like
this is our issue
this the one thing that sort of unites
them all together limited government
what does that mean and when do they
vote for it hey that's a great question
because i'm looking
you know i'm thinking of that that
weekend video you know from the super
bowl halftime
show like where where all this where are
all the limited government republicans
at one thing we talk about quite a bit
is that you
you can name very specific things that
progresses and democrats say they must
have
right natural a path to naturalization
you know public option or universal
health care
gun control you know what they're saying
we must
have now and the republicans are saying
don't do that
don't do that but they're not doing
anything themselves right no they've
always been the party
i've mostly been the party of no hold
your horses yeah
not even know just well think about what
the term of being what
what does the term conservative really
mean is someone who has always sort of
just played it safe
not doing anything drastic trying to
keep with tradition that's
largely what conservatives have always
been about and they're getting
arms manufacturing deals well bribes
whatever you want to call them
funding and uh oil the oil industry is
behind them so they
don't want it to change they want to
right continue the great train
means a lot everything comes down to
money i wonder how this is going to
impact
the future because before this segment
we were talking about propaganda
universities affecting our kids
trump brought in new voters he brought
in a lot of younger voters too
i i went to a bunch of trump rallies and
i talked to people you know to young men
who are like 20
and they said political correctness was
the issue why they decided to vote
republican
not much else trump was actually
fighting for specific things
sort of he represented certain things he
was fighting
to end these free trade agreements to
bolster american manufacturing that was
something finally people saw and they
agreed with
whereas the republicans were basically
like just not the democrat right
now we have this wave you know young
people every every every year
there's a wave of you know generation of
young people who are now eligible to
vote
these people these young people are now
entering the ranks of american voters
with a crippled gop that people are
leaving and
don't care for anymore so if they are
conservative or at least
not far left where do they go do we
ultimately see the rise of a new
political party or several or what
here's the thing
when it comes to people actually
entering the voting booth most people
think about what
what their vote actually means like is
it actually going to be counted
in a way that it matters and when they
think about the
dichotomy the two-party system
republican democrat
they realize that they can't always just
throw away their ballot i think most
people when they enter the voting booth
think they're going to vote for someone
that if they hate the other party
they're going to vote for
the party that's in opposition um
that that's kind of that is probably the
most simplest explanation i can give
because they may hate that particular
party that they're voting for
but they'll do it to try to stave
whatever may happen whatever may change
from the other party taking over right
i would ask please don't vote with hate
in the future
vote for not against no you just vote
for the lesser of two evils i mean
that's what the media tells us to do
that's clearly what we should do
also another thing to kind of think
about with this news article a lot of
these polls are usually
very very wrong and two that's true
usually the conservatives are very
underrepresented
in them so the polling industry is is an
industry that i absolutely do not trust
well but it's not polling this is the
actual hard numbers from the secretary
of state's office
tracking party membership well yeah well
yeah but but even when it comes to that
we have to understand
republicans and conservatives usually
are the types not
to be very public about who they support
or why they support
and a lot of times they they surprise
people at the polls because
they actually vote but they don't tell
anyone who they voted for that's why a
lot of the exit polls a lot of the other
polls are wrong and even though they
might be transferring parties right now
it still doesn't directly represent
yeah it still doesn't i mean i think
they're just disenfranchised this
franchise not just by trump not just by
the republicans but how can you not be
disenfranchised
with joe biden i mean i if you're not
maybe if you're not paying attention and
if you're in la la land which a lot of
people
are but if you're paying attention you
are absolutely disenfranchised with joe
biden
i mean biden is remarkably doing things
that everybody hates
he rescinds this rule on chinese
propaganda he rescinded so he suspect
i'm sorry suspended the rule in china's
republican he suspended a rule
keeping china out of our electrical grid
and like why so that's got conservatives
pissed off
but the left is saying he promised two
thousand dollar checks
he promised 50 dollar minimum wage he's
not doing any of those things either so
he's basically building a coalition
against him
yeah he banned the term china virus
because
he wanted to fight coveted racism i mean
he banned
language as he's making sure americans
to get into the united states have to
get a covet test but if you're a migrant
you don't even get coveted when you
cross the u.s border
but american citizens returning back to
their country you have to have a
covenant what if these people coming in
these migrants have coveted
yes yeah that's the point that's the
point that tucker carlson was talking
about yesterday in this first segment
which is something that i i think shows
you who
biden is really interested in this
disenfranchising of conservative voters
is worrisome
because you've got a bunch of people now
feeling like there's no outlet
and they're hearing things like what
luke is saying you mean if i fly in i
gotta get a test
but these people can just walk across
the border no problem
and joe biden is is creating a pathway
for these people but making it harder
for americans
that's going to make people lose it it
really does feel like the joke you know
this is the joke we've been making they
keep throwing more at us just to see
what how far we're willing to take it
i'm a little skeptical about that type
of story because
you you might hear it happen at one
particular checkpoint but it might not
it might be the exception not the rule
because i mean think about all these
detention centers that are housing a lot
of these migrants i mean
we talked obviously we talked about like
the child separation policy in 2018
which is
awful policy we should pull the story up
it's on the daily mail they also covered
it and they
really about how migrants are not being
tested
but uh american citizens who are coming
back have to have a
you know negative test in order to enter
the country i mean just think about i
mean because a lot of these detention
centers are controlled by hhs yeah well
now they're no no
no they're not detention centers they're
expansion centers they're expensive
so they're okay that's so kind of lingo
that they're using now
what is that what does that even mean
overflow they're overflow centers
so we have to figure out are those
overflow centers controlled by hhs or by
dhs because
those two those two uh federal agencies
basically control the flow of people
into the united states
and a lot of the detention facilities
that we saw that we thought were
controlled by
uh dhs are actually controlled by hhs
that's health and human services
yes that's that's the that's the the
federal agency that's
been trying to do all the covid
operation warp speed vaccine
basically the federal government's
response to all this has basically been
controlled by hhs
sorry sorry i i didn't mean that was a
very well keep going i was just
wondering if you found the rvhs
well i found the partner talking about
tucker carlson yeah blasting biden for
releasing thousands of migrants into the
us without giving them covet tests
as texas sheriff says the policy will
create irreparable harm
and that's that's that's i mean that's
the gist of it that's it that needs
investigation that that is
that sounds too crazy to be real but
again we live in the crazy world
[Laughter]
these these people who are leaving the
republican party probably were barely in
the republican party
when i was uh when i was in florida
there was a trump rally in fort
lauderdale
and i was just talking some random trump
supporters i i talked to not one
one republican i i talked to a small
handful of people maybe
just sh just shy of a dozen and they all
basically said the same thing
oh i'm i'm not in any party or anything
like that i think oh i i've never voted
before
i was just gonna say that trump
supporters trump is not a republican
he's not a conservative
he ran as a republican but
even you know the the most conservative
people will tell you
trump is not a conservative he is he is
a nationalist populist
he is in many ways an opportunist and
i think i s the the greatest analogy i
ever heard
uh about trump is that he's like a couch
whoever sits on him last that's what's
left on his brain
like that's what he's thinking about so
like whoever gets in his ear the last
the the last person who gets in his ear
that's one that's on his mind that's
what's probably go
he's going to be tweeting about or well
he can't tweet anymore but that's what
he would be talking about
he could go on gab r.i.p in peace but he
won't
depress i think you're right that not
maybe not that we need a new political
party but people want to do that they
want to we need it
and we need it what i think is that if
we don't start it literally
me and you like if we don't start it it
won't happen
i mean that's the problem i'm not
interested in being involved in a
political that's the thing everyone
hates it
i don't want to be a politician i don't
hate myself right exactly like
that you have to find someone who
particularly
loathes themselves in order to start
that
you need you ever see that i love this
is my favorite references of late the
feature rom episode about the clone
presidents
was it john jackson and jack johnson no
i think your three cent titanium tax
goes too far
well i think your three cent titanium
titanium tax doesn't go too far enough
for the same person fry is like they
look like the same person
and then leela's like it's because they
are that's that's what we have
and and that's what you need you need
somebody who has no real thoughts or
opinions and you hand them a stack of
paper saying here are the things you
have to say and they go okay
and they get votes could you build a
system where that it totally satiates
the military-industrial complex
and everybody involved but somehow
creates a system that will evolve us out
of it
i don't know green party
so like with with energy would it be
like an elect election no
i'm saying the actual green party maybe
i don't know they seem to be the only
party saying that they we don't need the
military industrial complex but i guess
i guess i guess the libertarian party
might be on the same wavelength but yeah
but we've all seen the meme with the
scraggly looking fox
you know that's true you think you'd
have a better chance of starting a new
party
or co-opting like the green party you
have to go out there this is why trump
didn't
trump was actually part of the reform
party when in 2000 he left it because
they were too
extreme and then he joined the gop later
on after being a democrat for so long
because he knew he figured out a way
to speak towards a lot of different
people from all different parts of the
then we're talking about political
spectrum because obviously the political
spectrum doesn't exist anymore
but people all across the spectrum
and find something that resonates with
them and it is literally as simple as
these people are out to get you i'm in
the way
that's why they hate me oh and
that was sort of he was a knock against
the entire establishment both democrat
and republican because he was just not
part of it he was the outsider
uh he was the billionaire outsider who
came in
like a wrecking ball miley cyrus style
basically saying i am going to change
the entire system
and then what ended up happening was he
because he was basically laughed out of
the prime well he wasn't left out of the
primary but people
you know did not take his candidacy
seriously from the get-go because of
whatever rhetoric he said uh you know
starting from his very first
political rally um he couldn't hire the
right advisors
and he ended up getting people like
carter page and george papadopoulos who
didn't really know what they were doing
and then they get wrapped up in this
whole like russia probe but then he
couldn't fill his
his actual cabinet with people who
actually believed in him
they were just opportunists trying to
basically get a job
and pardon for someone they knew or a
pardon for someone they knew
but there were just as many
opportunities that surrounded
trump president trump than president
trump himself
it's just i mean every so so everybody
was working against him i was reading
something earlier that
when he was trying to draft his
executive orders initially
the olc was just not like basically not
office of legal counsel
yeah they were supposed to be saying
okay here's how you can make your
executive order work
and they would purposefully leave holes
so that it could be destroyed in the
courts
i don't know if that's true that was
something i was reading no they're there
there was a direct and
there was incentive to make sure that
trump failed
within the republican party because
they realized that he took control of
he was he was the republican party when
he was president
everything was about him he was the
center of the universe
and establishment republicans were on on
the outside
and they realized that if if
actually democrats took a lesson from
from from republicans in 2016.
when bernie was winning all those states
in their early primaries he won what he
win he went
well iowa still hasn't decided uh he won
uh new hampshire and then he won uh
uh nevada um was there a third state in
there before
i don't know but anyways he had enough
delegates as if he won
iowa and then south carolina came up
what happened right right before super
tuesday
so joe biden predictably won south
carolina
but then the establishment decided they
were not going to let
an insurgency from bernie sanders happen
so they all coalesce behind joe biden
yeah amy klobuchar michael bloomberg
pete buddha judge
all dropping out in the span of like two
days and endorsing joe biden what
happened on on tuesday
super tuesday he won almost
i think all but two states and
that was it well because he the the
other candidates were splitting the vote
yeah exactly but they realized that this
is what happened this was the folly of
the the republican party the republican
establishment i should say
in 2016 is that they thought you know
you had the marco rubio you had the ted
cruz you had
john kasich he had scott walker all of
them thought they could take on trump
and he just picked them off one by one
if they all coalesce behind a particular
establishment candidate
they probably would not have nominated
donald trump plus trump was fun
it was very fun watching him make fun of
jeb and turn people into memes yeah
calling rand paul ugly
well yeah even elizabeth warren wasn't
with bernie she was still sticking
around and everyone was like hey
elizabeth you're kind of hurting bernie
here with all of this and
that was the plan yeah so and it's
amazing how people believe elizabeth
warren was like progressive
she's what did i say she's hillary
clinton wearing a bernie sanders mask
she's the only one that actually even
said something about social media and
the big tech oligarchs right and then
she stopped
so it's like she came out of the defense
of wall street during the during the
gamestop rebellion and they were when
they were challenging the hedge fund
she's like who are these people
what are they doing oh yeah great
progressive elizabeth warren defender of
wall street
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you